look at a quest like in the boobs thank
you
why was that Baker with a you I live at
USS I can't stop anybody are you song
actually
[Applause]
get you out sir they're gonna do it they
take down SK Telecom in the reverse
sweep and Ryu doesn't have to die
anymore
[Applause]
the rivalry between Katy and SKT two of
South Korea's largest telecom companies
is one of the oldest in eSports dubbed
the telecom war it has defined
generations of players and shaped the
history of entire games in Korea The
Crucible from which eSports emerged no
teams have battled for longer than SK
Telecom t1 and kt rolster it is a battle
that has raged for years in stadiums on
TV the telecom war was foundational for
an industry that while still niche in
the West was already in full swing in
South Korea these books would have had
in me that I was until my father got
some knives and yeah guys something what
I was happening with the table
underneath which women out of global
role as TomTom to know women I can open
it up for SKT it all began with the Lim
boxer yo-hwan one of the greatest
starcraft brood war players of all time
[Music]
boxer was a godfather of Korean eSports
and years later people would call him
the first bong-ja it's a Korean pronoun
meant to raise oneself up that's used to
describe a Starcraft player who the
community agrees is the most dominant
player of his era
initially boxer founded a team named
Orion in 2002 and in December 2003 the
team's name changed to for union but in
2004 SK Telecom's sponsored the org and
SK Telecom t1 was born
if SKT was built around boxer in the
early 2000s KT centered around Hong
yellow jinho created as Raptors in 1998
the organization became the ktf magic
ends in March 2001 the org would change
its name twice more in 2009 before
settling on kt rolster kt became known
for their willingness to spend big money
on their roster yellow was known for his
aggressive zerg play style and had one
of the best CB teas in the business he
was a frequent finalist in OSL from 2001
to 2005 though he never won his biggest
obstacle boxer
[Music]
yellow and boxers rivalry would become
one of the game's biggest with Katie and
SKT stars frequently butting heads on
the game's biggest stages even before
SKT was founded and though their
lifetime record was fairly close
boxer always seemed to clinch the
matches that mattered most
come on up
[Music]
[Applause]
but even as SKT and Katie's players
competed for trophies in the individual
competitions a new battlefield loomed
one that would become one of Starcraft's
most popular and influential and one
that would set the framework for modern
eSports as we know it pro league
[Music]
the team-based League became one of the
game's most popular competitive staples
and the format which saw both 1v1 and
2v2 matches would go on to define the
telecom war the format for the 2005
skypro League was simple two rounds each
with a winner then a grand final in
which the best teams from both rounds
faced off for all the glory
since SKT won both round 1 and round 2
the top three teams from both played in
the grand final tournament but the final
two teams came down to fate
played in front of a packed stadium the
skypro lead grand finals in 2005 was the
biggest early competition in the telecom
war and much like many battles between
SKT and KT that were yet to come
Katie couldn't overcome their rivals
[Music]
after the 2005 finals both teams entered
a period of decline ktf stop players
were getting old and many retired or
were forced to enter the air force in
2006 boxer announced that he'd also
received his draft letter and would
leave his team for the air force then in
2007 everything changed
his name is Li flash yung ho and he is
widely seen as the best Starcraft player
of all time he was only 14 when he made
his professional debut
[Applause]
flash was more than just a young prodigy
she went on a record-setting period of
dominance in the months after his first
OSL win in 2008 and that wouldn't be the
last record he set flash was so good
that he almost single-handedly skewed
the Pro League results between s Katie
and Katie where SKT dominated early
bouts between the rival organizations
Katie routinely got the upper hand prior
to the release of Starcraft 2 in the end
of KeSPA era brood war Katie one Pro
League in the 2009-2010 season and in
the 2010-2011 season beating SKT to do
it both times and though SKT did manage
to topple Katie in 2011-2012 season one
flashes dominance in the OSL msl and
other individual competitions could not
be matched by 2012 the Korean eSports
scene was changing dramatically the
release of Starcraft 2 in July 2010 saw
a shift in the community and though many
players continued to play brood war the
new blood and major international
eSports dollars flowing into Starcraft 2
divided the scene there was one other
factor League of Legends though the game
had been out for some time in the West
the release of a Korean server was a
watershed moment for League of Legends
and with the time of brood war beginning
to wane both Katie and SKT made the jump
to League of Legends in late 2012 Katy
created kt rolster a and b while SKT
acquired a roster that would go on to
become SK Telecom t1 number one in
February 2013 SKT created their second
team SK Telecom t1 number two later t1 K
which they built around a prom
Singh rookie named Lee faker sang-hyuk
Katy were quick to make a name for
themselves with a strong showing in
champions winter 2012-2013 and both orgs
put up strong results in the spring but
they were both on the upswing and by
summer 2013 Katie and SKT were the teams
to beat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
faker had matured since his rookie
tournament and was beginning to make a
case for himself as one of the best
players in the world and the bullets
talent hild roster also boasted players
who were beginning to cement their
legacies and on a rainy day in August in
a huge field near the Jamsil Olympic
Stadium in Seoul the two orcs clashed in
the finals for the first time in league
though SKT had individual star power KT
were seen as having stronger team play
and they got off to a strong start but
SKT didn't back down 20 minutes render
Ryu takes off his headphones and there
it is a 20 minute surrender in game 3
and we are going to Game five it all
came down to a pivotal Game five with
both faker and Ryu blind picking Zed KT
managed to get a small lead early the
pain train is coming through the river
there's the fear on the impact he goes
down as well and KT a good series of
events for them but SKT would not be
denied and just past the 30 minute mark
s Katie's first Champions title was all
but secured there goes to print there's
just nothing games he can do yes no
there's not there's not this is SK
Telecom's for a minute
but faker wasn't done Baker may be in
trouble you're dead Bart Chrysler clean
it up for real oh look at the glass look
at the boat thank the qss bullet space
the most famous outplay in the history
of league was the icing on the cake for
SKT and they completed the reverse sweep
in what went down as one of the greatest
series of league ever played it was a
new game but for the rival orgs there
were shades of brood wars early days
Katy were good but not quite good enough
because of the way world seating worked
at the time second place was not good
enough to secure Katy a berth two worlds
worlds that year was s Katie's to win
and though they still had their doubters
[Applause]
SK Telecom g1 for the championship hands
down I've got my tickets here I got
tickets to the Korean hype train and I
will be giving him out
thank you money I appreciate you like
your SKT favorite but I think it's more
time for thanks coach no thanks I'm
going to boil I'm gonna have to go ahead
to well as well Boyle club were no match
one of the World Finals going to SK
Telecom t1 lots of kills back and forth
but it's SK Telecom's they can game to
the world finally a twenty minute game
they will be the seeds of three
champions here at the Staples Center
SKT returned home victorious and
unstoppable they didn't drop a single
game in the group stage of champions
winter they swept Samsung blue in the
quarterfinals and secured a rematch
against the bullets in semies this time
it wasn't close
[Music]
[Music]
SKT swept their rivals and cruise
through the finals as well completing
what is still the only perfect season in
Korean league history going to combined
50 nano across six series if KT had
dominated the end of brood war this new
game this new era was SK T's to claim
they had the best player in the world
and a strong enough line-up to crush the
game's toughest competition league of
legends was theirs to dominate until it
wasn't interesting to note that K has
looked shaky in the past couple of weeks
or be just shaky as they've ever looked
at you all day with lazy and laziness
I feel like fakers pics have been a bit
cocky they've got a lot of think about
the air in the eyes of faker that is
terror right there I can't believe we're
seeing SK Telecom K lose a game here or
a team that didn't lose any games for an
entire tournament last season 2014 was a
rough year for SKT especially the t1 K
roster they placed top 8 in both spring
and summer but losses in the regional
finals saw them failed to qualify for
Worlds
meanwhile the t1 s roster featuring the
likes of Marin easyhoon bang and wolf
finished 4th in the summer split both kt
rosters were also unsuccessful in the
regional finals there was no question
faker was a strong player or that KT
could compete but to some it seemed like
the telecom team's time had come and
gone League was still relatively young
especially compared to the lifespan of
brood war in Korea but with an explosion
of eSports worldwide and the existing
talent pool and Korean orgs the scene
had matured quickly that's really what
what separates Korea as a region from a
lot of the other regions we're trying to
get there with all our infrastructure
wise but they have already Hazzard said
they have multiple sets of coaches the
Korean teams they know exactly how to
punish mistakes can't you be a do the
same can't fnatic can't cloud9
do the same thing some analysts still
see 2014 as the most competitive year in
Korea's history
and it seemed like the game was entering
a new era one dominated by Samsung but
it didn't happen that way with a huge
influx of money into the Chinese scene
all 10 of Samsung's starting players
were spirited away by lucrative
contracts many other players departed
for other regions which at the time
could offer contracts larger than many
Korean orgs dubbed the great Korean
Exodus it remains the single greatest
redistributing of talent in the game's
history 2015 saw other changes with the
abolishing of sister teams and a move
towards a league system rather than the
tournament format champions had been
running since 2012 between an
amalgamation of talent onto single
rosters and the departure of some of the
region's most dominant players it was a
reset for the scene in many ways and
both SKT and Katie looked to capitalize
sk telecom t1 an organization that won
season three worlds and they still do
have thank you faker so two of those
that worlds team roster is still on this
kt looks like they finally gone with
their their starting lineup and that
will be scored the jungle and of course
the sports progress that the jungle
should be very exciting to see those
game a new force on the scene the GE
Tigers topped the regular season but SK
T's new combined roster featuring Marin
bengi easyhoon faker bang and wolf was
too much come playoff time and they
swept the finals right here 304 SK
Telecom be safe
with his fifth dragon Bank coming up
terrowin gorilla trying to delay long
enough for prey to come back stab Joyce
well I don't know if they can head right
here they're gonna try easy baby
literally received wiser members the guy
goes down bar and gets that kill on to
the support another jumper Mara and now
it will end
snap getting low whoa there it is the
first Nexus turret down the second Nexus
turret down a triple cooper Morin and
SKT with Todd with easyhoon takes the
three Oh JJ we'll see you Katie didn't
make playoffs SKT stumbled at msi but
regrouped in time for summer in playoffs
hungry for another domestic title a
surging SKT and Katy met in the finals
for the first time since summer 2013 so
exciting because of the stories of these
organizations SK Telecom versus Katy
it's been a decade of libel read between
these two organizations across games and
we had what I consider the best best of
five ever played in League of Legends
history in summer 2013
but in the end Katy were no match the
rest of the year and 2016 along with
much of 2017 would be about one team and
one team Olmec
[Applause]
SKT will be your first ever two-time
world champions
sk t 3 owed them in the playoffs on
their way to their 2016 spring title
another kill for faker looks like this
is it guys
SKT if they can win this fight they can
win the game there goes the Nexus turret
still fighting there goes the Nexus SKT
just needs to focus it they do getting a
few more kills on the way but they're
gonna finish it off think yeah okay they
can want to keep fighting up this one
Center there we go SKT going to the
sprint grand finals what a match and an
end so the 304 SK Telecom in the telecom
war by summer 2016 people were starting
to think of the telecom war as just a
remainder of a bygone era
the fans KT earned with their showings
in 2013 and 2014 had become a punchline
to be a KT fan was to know heartbreak oh
yeah go for arrow can't quite finish
them off but they still have 25 seconds
on something 20 on scores they're gonna
go for this one the Nexus tour is being
engaged on its 28 minutes into the game
very early victory here if Johnny comes
up can they finish this maker goes for a
double ban pulverized there by wolfies
going low on mana duke - before though
they'll be able to finish off the Sivir
and that's going to be the game going
over to SKT very convincing here and
Game three
having a lead rolling it away at Baron
and SK Telecom will win the telecom war
yet again but after fighting their way
to the second round of playoffs that
summer KT earned themselves another
crack at the unassailable SKT it is
definitely going to be a barn burner
very exciting kt looking to make their
fourth consecutive summer final SK
Telecom trying to keep their streak of
victories alive ever since we went into
the league or mat they have yet to lose
a season first place every single time
this time it was SKT that went up 2-0
but with echoes of their 2013 final Katy
brought it back to Game five and this
time it was enough in the reverse sweep
bringing it back three games in a row
and they are going to the finals this is
Katie's Redemption
this is scores revenge for three years
ago the reverse sweep coming back to
take out SK Telecom here and Rio doesn't
have to die anymore
KT weren't able to defeat the Rox Tigers
in finals and in classic KT fashion they
missed out on worlds while SKT managed
to become the first team to defend their
world title KT fans were exuberant for
one glorious day but their win was still
a footnote on the year 2016 still
belonged to SKT in the end KT fans
tasted what it was like to topple their
demons and the organisation wanted more
so in 2017 they returned to their early
broodwar roots if SKT was a problem they
would bring in the best talent the world
had to offer in an attempt to defeat
them I mean let's be real how many teams
in the world do you not look at
every role and be like oh I take the kt
rolster player over you SKT maybe apart
from that not many teams
smeb score pawn deft mata five of the
best players to ever touch the game
Katie had crafted the roster to topple
SKT they had crafted it to win with the
return of former Samsung players to
Korea and the proven dominance of smeb
and score and their physicians it seemed
like Katie's 2017 roster was too good to
fail but it didn't work
Katie made it to the finals in the
spring split but were toppled 3-0 by SKT
[Applause]
[Applause]
in the summer split in round three of
the playoffs SKT won a closer series 3-2
to SKT won all four of their regular
season meetings then kt missed out on
worlds yet again kt built their team to
defeat SKT but they couldn't shake their
demon they were good in 2017 but they
were not good enough of course at the
end of the year neither was SKT
[Applause]
galaxy there 2017 champions
fans saw 2017 as a failure despite
results that would be incredible for
another team and SK T's 2018 spring
split was inauspicious at best after
struggling to find a version of the
roster that worked for much of the
regular season they managed to narrowly
qualify for the playoffs but for once
KT entered playoffs with the upper hand
for once Katie had the head to head
during the regular season for once Katie
were the favourites KT season ended in
defeat at the hands of the Africa freaks
but even though they haven't won a
domestic title since 2014 they proved
that with a little help from new
editions you Cal andrush their Ross or
can do what it was built to do when the
telecom history coming towards the top
cytologist being corralled by martha
who's omniscient
standing in front of him stomping the
poppy going arm and kt rolster they've
done it it's the 3-1 victory in the
telecom the playoffs around 80 roster
eliminate SK Telecom t1 at their lowest
position in the history of the LC game
SKT and Katie's rivalry has taken
different shapes in different games
generations of players and coaches have
played their part but each time their
players sit down in front of a keyboard
to play there's something else there an
extra boost pushing them to play their
best to be better always better in the
end their position in one split or in
one tournament doesn't matter
fans will still pack the studio when
it's time for Katie and SKT
to face off they'll still scream hiding
when the game begins and they will still
roar with pride when their side is
victorious kt rolster and SK Telecom
have been jockeying for position in
eSports for nearly as long as eSports
have existed both sides have won
skirmishes both sides have triumphed in
battle but the telecom war is far from
over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]